how many times has the Lord brought him
back six Cornish sound Kostas tower
hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones Season 6
foreshadowing video just all my favorite
times that the show foreshadowed some
big WTF event that hadn't happened yet
just careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far and
there is a new round of the giveaway
this week we're still doing the DVD
giveaway which is actually dropping in
the next week and a half so we might see
the first trailer then but all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video so here we
go starting with the pilot of course
it's the pilot they're gonna foreshadow
a ton of stuff not just for that first
season but for the rest of the show the
idea is is that for the best TV shows
the the shows where the show runners the
people behind the show have a very clear
idea for how the show begins and ends
they build a lot of extra things that
will set up later seasons in the pilot
so first big moment for shadowing the
white walkers are coming and the dead
are coming with them most of the drama
in the first couple of seasons
particularly season 1 is between great
houses a game of froze the literal Game
of Thrones that different people are
playing on the show the supernatural war
gets teased out much slower next big
moment of foreshadowing this is more of
a visual metaphor the direwolf killed by
the stag foreshadowing Ned Stark's death
at the end of the season Ned Stark
killed by a stag Joffrey Baratheon not
too long after that Jaime kind of
foreshadows losing his hand when he
talks to Tyrion about bran stark falling
out the window he'll be a [ __ ] it's
grotesque give me a good clean death any
time and yeah I'm sure Jaime did wish
for death a couple times when he was
recovering from his hand wound but he's
largely a stronger character because of
it now this next one is a little more
literal Melisandre burning the leeches
for Stannis she speaks the names Robb
Stark Joffrey Baratheon and Balon
Greyjoy of those people the only one
who's still alive on the show for the
time being is Balon Greyjoy if you've
read the books you kind of know where
this is headed please use spoiler tags
if you want to talk about it in the
comments but Balon Greyjoy is still
alive on the show as of season 6 next
big one
Theon kind of a douchebag early in the
series very tragic character now maybe
he'll find Redemption but during season
two when he assaults Winterfell when he
tries to take it he says to maester
Luwin saying that he doesn't want to be
thought of as a fool and a eunuch
amongst his people what is he now he has
literally lost his manhood thing
to Ramsay Bolton during season four
Littlefinger predicts Tywin's death when
he says people die at their dinner
tables people die in their beds they die
squatting over their chamber pots next
one also a really awesome Littlefinger
moment when he's talking to Sansa in the
crypts of Winterfell she's standing at
the statue of her aunt Lyanna
remembering her and Littlefinger tells
her the story of the tourney at
Harrenhal when Rhaegar crowned Liana
over his wife Elia Martell with the blue
roses
Sansa replies with yet but Rhaegar
kidnapped and raped my aunt and
Littlefinger just tweaks his head a
little bit and says did he as if he's
asking a question now each character on
the show probably has their own idea
about what happened between Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna stark but this is
the show just for shadowing that maybe
Rhaegar and Lyanna had a relationship
together
maybe they had a secret baby together so
this is one in a couple different
moments that foreshadow R + L equals J
later in the pilot they also
foreshadowed Daenerys on Bert when she
gets into the really hot bath and
doesn't seem to feel it like it's
supposed to be scalding hot but she
steps out and seemingly has no burns
Targaryen have a mythical resistance to
fire that doesn't actually exist
technically when she actually survives
being burnt by fight like in the funeral
pyre for Khal Drogo when the dragons are
hatched blood magic is in play so it's a
bit of a special case Targaryens can
totally burn and Fire as evidenced by
one Targaryen king who thought he was an
actual dragon and tried to drink
wildfire there was also the tragedy at
summer hall that killed egg from the
Duncan ake series so Targaryens can
totally burn unless magic is in play if
they did want to prove that Daenerys was
fireproof though they could totally have
her stand right in front of drogon and
have to just open up that would be so
hilarious just take a bath and Fire like
it's no big deal
this next one's a fun one two weddings
on Game of Thrones are always a terrible
idea to not get married on Game of
Thrones during season two Varys and
Tyrion are talking about how much they
hate the ringing of the bells in the
city because they always ring for
something really terrible happening like
a king dying some horror or city being
under siege and then Tyrion adds or a
wedding so wedding bells also equal
disaster bells stay away
when Oberyn Martell was agreeing to be
Tyrians champion he foreshadows
and winding up in the fighting pits
Tyrians like maybe you shouldn't drink
before you go into the fighting pits
tomorrow and Oberon responds with you
learned this during your years in the
fighting pits well during season five
Tyrion and Serge Ora gets sent to the
fighting pits that's how they wind up
back in front of tenaris and at the end
of season four the three-eyed Raven
foreshadows brands power over nature
when he says you'll never walk again but
you will fly now he's not just talking
about him skin changing into animals
he's talking about a grander power over
nature that will allow him to see across
time and space so he will be flying over
planet oast in more ways than one and
probably one of my other big favorites
is the resurrection of Jon Snow with
beric Dondarrion how many times has the
Lord of Light brought him back in
Melisandre flips her [ __ ] she has no
idea that that's possible so even though
she walks around with that smug look on
her face there's still a lot that she
doesn't know about her own magic so let
me know in the comments what is your
favorite moment of foreshadowing on Game
of Thrones either for a specific moment
or something that's gonna happen way
later in the series sometimes they're
really subtle like with the stag in the
direwolf sometimes they're a little more
literal like with Melisandre sleeches
I definitely think my favorite is either
a tie between Lyanna Stark and the Crips
or beric Dondarrion being brought back
six times so I've also got a new Star
Wars video that I'm working on so I'll
probably post that first tomorrow but I
might also try to get a game of Thrones
Q&A out before walking dead if I don't
then I'll just post it on Monday so no
worries while you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for the Game of
Thrones Season 6 behind-the-scenes video
and you can click here to learn a little
bit more about resurrection on Game of
Thrones in A Song of Ice and Fire thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight